Sam bankman freed arrested in the
Bahamas I am astounded that it took this
long they were apparently Democrats were
like well we're not going to go after
him we're not it's like okay we get it
he gave you money unbelievable
unbelievable Martin shkreli said that it
could take them up to five years to
prosecute so he was like a couple days
ago I think on his YouTube channel was
saying it's not that big of a deal they
took four four years and nine months to
go after him is what he was saying but
uh then the next thing I saw is he's
arrested how long did it take him to go
after a Bernie Madoff good question
right away so as soon as they found out
but he was doing that how long was he
doing exactly but but we found out about
this scam a while they had a chance to
lawyer up they had a chance to destroy
evidence they had a chance to cover up
their tracks They had a chance they
lured up with Elaine Maxwell's lawyers
okay yeah so they have some of the most
powerful attorneys in the world right
now working with them as they had an
advantage to be able to do a lot of
crazy stuff that they could have hidden
so much they could have covered up so
much they could have got the lava bit
they could have got so many different
actions that that could have derailed
the the larger possible Justice here and
I truly do believe that it's only
because of the pressure only because of
the coverage of independent journalists
specifically on Twitter that made them
do something and if it wasn't for this
particular pressure from Twitter from
Independent Media I wouldn't see them
doing anything it was broken by a
Twitter user wasn't it just a I think it
was crypto employee or something was the
guy's name there was there was a Twitter
user uh that just followed some leads or
whatever and and started exposing it and
started really uh putting out the the
information on Sam bankman freed and and
autism Capital also did a bunch of good
work on it and it was these like it was
like these independent
um Twitter users and Elon started
picking the independent Twitter users
that's the internet man come on I love
it hey they're serious groups
autism Capital exposed it like right
when the crash was happening there was a
hack at FTX and 300 million dollars in
crypto disappeared off their Network
good I want to know where that money
went that I find that money and bring it
back I think that Sam should have to I
don't want to see him get his life
annihilated I want to see him pay those
people back yeah but how
raise crowdfund the money you know
people obviously Sam like if he knows
enough people that he's paying hundreds
of millions to like Democratic don't
time for the Democracy to get back to
Sam pay him back the thing is like I
don't know well I mean I don't know I
don't know enough about the actual the
actual scheme that he had going on to to
speak on it so I can't really say but I
just can't imagine him I know that he
was lying about having the money so I
can't imagine him being able to produce
the money that he stole I I just don't
see how anyone would would I mean who's
gonna fund it yeah
I don't know I suggested what if we use
tax money and I was like you status you
communist no well I mean I was like okay
what if we do a crowdfunding campaign to
help these people out because there's
people about to that lost like their own
their last seventy thousand dollars it
was all on FTX announced at zero yeah I
lost 100 bucks I was mad like some
people lost everything what happened
like you just logged in your account
yeah I tried to take my hundred dollars
out and it's so similar to The Great
Depression what happened when all these
margin calls got pulled back all these
people were investing on margin loans
and then when the when the crash happens
you lose they call your margin they take
your money to pay it pay off the
undervalued asset or whatever
and these people it's a different
situation because he was actually it
looks like he was advertently frauding
his investors he was telling him your
money's going to be safe in this account
at FDX but what's happening is they're
funneling it to Alameda research and
then using that to invest wait wait
until people find out about the American
banking system
the American the American banking system
is backed by nuclear weapons no one's
going to do anything with anyone's gonna
do anything about the American banking
system
man I I
really do want to see Sam pay these
people back I think the righteous things
they only pay like a few cents an hour
in jail though
he's got to raise the money he's got to
know people well no hold on you know a
few billion hours well a few hundred
billion hours and maybe you can pay
something or at least pay back the small
investors the people that were in for
like nine grand and that was all they
had
and now they're working paycheck to
paycheck again making like a thirty
dollars a week you know extra than what
they can afford or something like that
like people it's cold it's cold outside
it's not it's got to do something we
can't do something what I I don't know
what I don't know what there is to be
done
um I think the best thing that
I don't know that there is I don't know
that there is anything that can be done
to the people that lost money
uh to make I don't think there's
anything that can be done to make them
whole
um
yeah I don't see him I don't I'm sure
I'm sure when you signed up too you
signed an agreement saying that you
recognize risk and blah blah but they
were blatantly told we are not touching
your money FTX will not touch this money
it's going into an account it's going to
be safe we're gonna hold it and give it
back to you and they were taking it into
this other what sludge funds that they
had where like all the money was mixed
together and this thing is that's why
Sam bankman freed needs to suffer not
physically suffer but suffer it needs to
in there needs to be there needs to be
repercussions that disincentivize people
from doing what he did now the honey
pot's big because you're talking about
billions of dollars so the payoff is
really really really really really worth
the risk to a lot to a lot of people but
if you make the penalty you know bad
enough
hopefully it would deter people I don't
think it will man you know we've got
there's always going to be people that
are going to break the law right you
know you know we've got Chicago you got
gun laws you got murder laws you got
death penalty and people are just oh is
Illinois death penalty I'm pretty sure
Illinois is that penalty right electric
chair I don't know maybe you're right
not because it is it is a blue State
yeah and to be honest with you even if
even if it is it is death penalty most
of your your your street crime like that
doesn't get death penalty because
usually it has to be something like
premeditated murder or something oh yeah
no since 2011 no more death penalty okay
yeah so there you go so um I've just
I've looked at that stuff and I just
don't I don't think criminal charges
deter people from committee crimes
they're supposed to they're supposed to
but they they do I think I think the
issue with all the crime we've seen and
the collapse that we're seeing in this
country is is based on a lack of
community that people don't respect each
other they don't fear each other they
don't care it used to be that the reason
you wouldn't Rob your neighbor's house
was because you were scared about what
your neighbors would say when they found
out you were the robber you would be
able to go to the grocery store then you
would be able to buy bread or meat now
it's just you go to a city and they're
like don't know you don't care yes Sam's
lack of compassion for the people that
used ftx's Stark he's done a lot of
interviews which people have said this
is this is a terrible move for someone
right after they commit a multi-billion
dollar uh fraud like he did or at least
I don't know if it's is it is it okay to
say he committed fraud or yes even if I
don't I mean just looks like he admitted
it on to Coffee Zilla and Twitter yeah
he said he said what he did was wrong he
said that you know what he did qualifies
as fraud what he admitted to meets the
definite edition of fraud so it's okay
to call it fraud see a patsy is there
somebody else that's stalls Mike because
he doesn't seem like the smartest guy
you know he's playing video now but yeah
he was known as like the next yeah
Warren Buffett they were saying yeah who
was saying that someone media
organization and he was funneling money
probably yeah yeah some of the most
discredited name names in corporate
media he was financing a lot of the the
media organizations just like Bill Gates
he was giving them a lot of money that
money buys you a lot of influence and
then the corporate media kisses your ass
let's be real it seems like if you do
the opposite of dream what Jim Cramer
says you'll be rich yeah they're they're
I believe there are Bots that counter
trade Jim Kramer you know what I'm going
at this as I hope that people get their
money back but you're right Phil he
needs there needs to be strict harsh
penalties for what he did because he
defrauded billions of dollars out of I
don't know how many tens of thousands of
humans lost their life savings how many
thousands maybe we got to bring back
some unusual punishment you know like
tarring and Feathering something like
that I mean you could you could make an
argument to allow the people that he
actually defrauded to take it into their
own hands but I mean yeah that's not a
good argument or it's not a good it's
not a good solution but it's a solution
that might deter people if you know
every everyone you defraud gets to beat
the absolute crap out of you we're in
the age of like impact investment right
now where people think the ends justify
the means if we're giving to things we
believe in then if other people get
screwed along the way it's worth it I
think that's Sam's sick mentality I mean
how many what many drugs was he using
different do you think that that I I
don't know if he's made any remarks uh
about this uh other than he the fact
that I've read headlines that talked
about his philanthropy I I read I don't
remember who wrote the the headline but
I I recall a headline that was something
like this is going to mess up his
ability to to uh do the the projects
that he was looking to help people
um I it was one of the more sycophantic
headlines I've ever seen about a person
that was accused of such such a
dramatic Financial crime but they call
it I think it was something like now his
dream projects won't be visualized
I mean it's not philanthropy they use
this cover word in order to just buy
people off and I mean especially when it
comes to the whole non-profit sector
there's a lot of criminals in that whole
sector that are just acting like they're
giving away their money when in reality
they're just making money for themselves
you'll get Bill Gates he was like I'm
gonna give away all my money he doubled
his money since saying that a couple
years ago that's not a coincidence it's
not an accident and I think you know
thinking deeper here I think there's a
big possibility that this SPF guy was a
patsy he was the last man holding the
bag and that there was a bigger
operation at hand here that was moving
around the billions of dollars in secret
shadow funds that uh are still
unaccounted for they call it the global
corporations are calling it um impact
investment where you invest in things
that you want to see happen regardless
of the return on your investment it's
just about giving money to things you
believe in in the tech sector they're
calling it effective altruism they're
they're they're mutilating the word
altruism and saying if there's a net
benefit if we have to hurt 99 people but
we help 100 it's worth it it's
effectively altruistic yeah to me that's
that's utilitarianism yeah it is
absolutely utilitarianism and a lot of
people got hurt in this risk like
unnecessary risk like Thanos like like
Thanos from Marvel you know he wants to
save the universe by killing half of
them right there you go
you know what you should make uh well I
don't know if the meme translates if
like some kind of Bargain Bin Thanos is
Bill Gates what expectation versus
reality Thanos snapping and then reality
it's Bill Gates going there are too many
people thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time